this program is brought to you by Emory
University
I wish I was you know spend a little
more time doing things one thing I
always reflect back on is I took part in
many activities at Emory everything from
the wheel to plane on intramural sports
and working for the Emory had a TV
program at the time when I was here
meaning in the sorority and a bunch of
other things internship opportunities
one thing I think I wish I would have
done is step back and focused maybe on a
few of the things and going full force
with those my education at Emory wasn't
just the classroom it was the community
which educating me and it was the
marketplace of ideas within the city of
Atlanta which also helped me value Miami
education probably more so than if I'd
gone to any other school in any other
locale as a freshman I wish I had
discovered low water park early but I
don't think I really discovered it until
my junior year when I took up running
and then I was in low water park four or
five times a week and its really the
highlight of my trips back to Emory
thing I talk about regarding Emory with
family and friends is how welcoming
everyone was when I first decided that I
wanted to come here the welcoming
continued from the first day I arrived
on campus and continued until after I
left and in fact still continues there's
such a strong undercurrent of inclusion
and invitation for parents for alumni
corporations foundations for neighbors
for friends and that makes it a very
welcoming and enriching place to be a
part of as a freshman I wish I knew that
it was really important to never skip
class I always paid a price when I did
that if I overslept or I had a conflict
but it's really important to go to every
class I think it's been a wonderful
experience and we've recommended it to
lots of people in our family and lots of
friends tell them about meeting my wife
here in freshman French class 45 years
ago and what a good experience that has
been for us I came here thinking I
wanted to be a doctor and what I really
learned at Emory was that really wasn't
what I wanted
do I just wanted to be an educated
person and I think Emery offered me
those opportunities to become an
educated person and introduced me to a
whole new world out there in terms of
diversity of my classmates in terms of
subject matter I'd never even given any
thought to and it has affected me for
the rest of my life as a freshman I wish
I had known to follow the great
professors no matter what discipline
there in even if they were outside my
discipline I also wish somebody had told
me to engage in whatever your passion is
from the beginning whether again it's a
mother's an extracurricular activity or
something you really want to study and
somebody had told me and I'm glad I knew
pursue the study abroad programs that
was something that really was a great
opportunity for me single most thing
that Emery well and that is that is
tough I think that it it crafts future
world leaders I wish I had known as a
freshman that how many opportunities
Emery actually had when I came here I
sort of focused on my little area of
academics and a couple of my friends and
that kind of thing I think if I'd gone
back now I would look at the whole
spectrum of opportunities and take
advantage of more of them at an earlier
stage if you happen to think you know
what you're majoring in and you're sort
of on a path already don't you know
don't limit yourself and if you're not
quite sure yet then really take
advantage and test the waters there are
so many so many great departments here
and explore the diversity of the student
body and take advantage of being in
atlanta and in the south and really you
know enjoy this part of the country
while you have a chance to be here what
I wish I knew as a freshman would be
that I am in command of my own time and
I must learn quickly quickly quickly how
to schedule and budget time which I
didn't learn until it was a little bit
too late one thing that I would urge
everyone to remember
emery is it's what you make it you could
get a world-class education at Emory if
you take the opportunity but you're you
make your own education at Emory with
the opportunity to make it the finest in
the world this is this is a real moving
place it's going places and you can just
feel that when you're on campus and it's
been fun for me to see how it still has
that sense of expansion and growth and
new frontiers even today I think what
both incoming freshmen as well as their
parents need to recognize in a very
positive way is that this is not simply
a four-year experience and that as much
as Emery is going to shape and influence
you as a student the the Emory
experience does not end when you
graduate and the relationships that
you've built the friendships that you've
made the lifelong learning the perpetual
impact that Emery has both on you as a
citizen and the LOM as well as on the
communities is going to stay with you
forever
cool is very supportive that no matter
what community the student comes from
that Emery will be a nurturing community
for them and it will be an easy
transition from whatever the community
they come from they'll be able to find
their niche here I think Emery is some
place now more so than when I went here
that is known internationally and when
you say that magical word you're going
to probably have a better chance of
getting in wherever you would like to
get in for that career and help pay your
parents back for all the way you're for
your education students and parents
should know that Emery cares about its
students and so never feel alone never
feel like you cannot go to someone for
help take advantage of your advisor your
professors academic counselors your
Resident Advisor your sophomore advisors
there's so many people here that want to
make sure your experience is phenomenal
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University